incumplimientos en el acuerdo de compra
anticipada y falta de estrategia para
garantizar las entregas que faltan eso
es lo que argumentó la comisión europea
en la demanda que presentó el viernes
pasado ante los tribunales belgas contra
astrazéneca lo que nos importa en este
caso es asegurarnos de que habrá una
entrega rápida de dosis suficientes para
los ciudadanos europeos lo que se
prometió sobre la base del contrato
así que la comisión inició esta acción
legal a nombre propio y en nombre de los
27 estados miembros que apoyan por
completo el proceso support for this
suicidio de acuerdo con la comisión el
laboratorio anglo sueco entregó sólo 29
8 millones de dosis en los primeros tres
meses del año y prevé entregar sólo 70
millones en el segundo trimestre frente
a las 300 millones de vacunas acordadas
el ejecutivo comunitario había informado
la semana pasada que debido a los
retrasos tampoco planea comprar 100
millones de dosis adicionales a las que
tiene derecho y desde ese momento
anunció la acción legal pero señaló que
primero quería contar con el apoyo
de todos los países del bloque pues
naciones como francia y alemania habían
reclamado ver la demanda antes de
presentar el actual proyecto maps
astrazéneca respondió en un comunicado y
aseguró que para finales de abril habrá
entregado casi 50 millones de dosis
astrazéneca ha cumplido con el acuerdo
de compra anticipada y se defenderá
firmemente en los tribunales las vacunas
son difíciles de fabricar como lo
demuestran los desafíos de suministro a
los que se enfrentan varias empresas en
europa y el mundo estamos avanzando al
enfrentar desafíos técnicos y nuestra
producción está mejorando el laboratorio
anglo sueco expuso que desea continuar
trabajando constructivamente con el
bloque y defendió que su compromiso es
ayudar al mundo sin obtener beneficios